to be fair do I think AI kills us all uh
I think AI kills everything we call like
society today but I do not think it
actually kills the human species I think
that's actually incredibly hard to do
you have a society like if we start over
that's tricky most of us don't know how
to do most things yeah but some of us do
and they'll be okay and they'll rebuild
after they uh
great AI
what's rebuilding look like how far like
how much do we lose like what is human
civilization done that's interesting
combustion engine electricity
so uh power and energy that's
interesting
like how to harness energy
well they're going to be religiously
against that
are they going to get back to uh like
fire
sure I mean they'll be a they'll be a
little it'll be like you know some kind
of Amish looking kind of thing I think I
think they're going to have very strong
taboos against technology
hmm like technology is almost like a new
religion technology is the devil yeah
and uh nature is God
sure to closer to nature but can you
really get away from AI if it destroyed
99 of the human species isn't it somehow
have a hole like a strong hold what's
interesting about
everything we build I think we're going
to build super intelligence before we
build any sort of robustness in the AI
we cannot build an AI that is capable of
going out into nature and surviving like
a um like a bird
right a bird is an incredibly robust
organism we've built nothing like this
we haven't built a machine that's
capable of reproducing
yes but
there's uh you know I work with Lego
robots a lot now I have a bunch of them
um
they're mobile
they can't reproduce but all they need
is I guess you're saying they can't
repair themselves but if you have a
large number if you have like 100
million of them let's just focus on them
reproducing right do they have
microchips in them okay then do they
include a Fab
no then how are they going to reproduce
well they're they it doesn't have to be
all on board right they can go to a
factory to a repair shop yeah but then
you're really moving away from
robustness yes all of life is capable of
reproducing without needing to go to a
repair shop life will continue to
reproduce in the complete absence of
civilization
robots will not so when the if if the AI
apocalypse happens
I mean the AIS are going to probably die
out because I think we're going to get
again super intelligence long before we
get robustness
what about if you just improve
the Fab to where
you just have a 3D printer that can
always help you
well that'd be very interesting I'm
interested in building that
of course you are you think how
difficult is that problem to have a
robot that uh
basically can build itself very very
hard
I think you've mentioned this like uh to
me or somewhere where people think it's
easy conceptually
and then they remember that you're going
to have to have a Fab yeah on board of
course
so 3D printer that prints a 3D printer
yeah yeah on legs
are hard
well because it's I mean a 3D printer is
a very simple machine right okay you're
going to print chips you're going to
have an atomic printer are you going to
dope the Silicon yeah right
how are you gonna hatch the Silicon
you're gonna have to have a a very
interesting kind of Fab if you wanna
have a lot of computation on board
but you can do like
structural type of robots that are dumb
yeah but structural type of robots
aren't going to have the intelligence
required to survive in any complex
environment what about like ants type of
systems we have like trillions of them
I don't think this works I mean again
like ants at their very core are made up
of cells that are capable of
individually reproducing they're doing
quite a lot a lot of computation that
we're taking for granted it's not even
just the computation it's that
reproduction is so inherent okay so like
there's two stacks of life in the world
there's bio the biological stack and the
Silicon stack the biological stack
starts with reproduction
reproduction is at the absolute core the
first proto-rna organisms were capable
of reproducing
right the Silicon stack despite as far
as it's come
is nowhere near being able to reproduce
yeah
so the the Fab movement
uh digital fabrication
Fabrication in the full range of what
that means is still in the early stages
yeah you're interested in this world
even if you did put a Fab on the machine
right let's say okay and we can build
apps we know how to do that as Humanity
we can probably put all the precursors
that build all the machines in the Fabs
also in the machine so first off this
machine is going to be absolutely
massive
I mean we almost have a like think of
the size of the thing required to
reproduce a machine today
right
like is our civilization capable of
reproduction can we reproduce our
civilization on Mars
if we were to construct a machine that
is made up of humans
like a company that can reproduce itself
yeah
I don't know it feels like like 115
people
I get so much harder than that
120.
I'm looking for a number I believe the
Twitter can be run by 50 people uh
I think that this is going to take most
of like it's just most of society right
like we live in one globalized world no
but you're not interested in running
Twitter you're interested in seeding
like um you want to see the civilization
and then because humans can like oh okay
you're talking about yeah okay so you're
talking about the humans reproducing and
like basically like what's the smallest
self-sustaining colony of humans yeah
yeah okay fine but they're not going to
be making five nanometer chips over time
they will I think you're being like we
have to expand our conception of time
here going back to the original uh time
scale I mean over across
maybe 100 Generations we're back to
making chips no if you see the colony
correctly
maybe or maybe they'll watch our
Colony die out over here and be like
we're not making chips don't make chips
nobody have to seed that Colony
correctly whatever you do don't make
chips chips are what led to their
downfall
hmm
well that is the thing that humans do
they they come up they construct the
devil a good thing and a bad thing and
they really stick by that and then they
murder each other over that there's
always one in the room who
murders everybody
[Laughter]
and usually makes tattoos and nice
branding do you need that that's
a question right Humanity works really
hard today to get rid of that
but I think they might be important yeah
this whole freedom of speech thing it's
it's the freedom of being an
seems kind of important right
man this thing this Fab this human Fab
that we constructed this human
civilization is pretty interesting and
now it's building artificial copies of
itself or artificial copies of various
aspects of itself that seem interesting
like intelligence
wonder where that goes
I like to think it's just like another
stack for life like we have like the
biostack life like we're a biostack life
and then the Silicon stack life but it
seems like the ceiling
or there might not be a ceiling and or
at least the ceiling is much higher for
the for the silicone stack oh no I don't
I we don't know what the ceiling is for
the biostack either the biostack the
biostack just seemed to move slower
um you have Moore's Law uh which is not
dead despite many proclamations uh in
the Ohio stack or the silicone in the
Silicon stack and you don't have
anything like this in the biostack so I
have a meme that I post that I tried to
make a meme it didn't work too well but
um I posted a picture of uh you know
Ronald Reagan and Joe Biden and you look
this is 1980 and this is 2020. yeah and
these two humans are basically like the
same right there's no there's no like
like they're
there's been no change in humans in the
last 40 years yeah and then I posted a
computer from 1980 and a computer from
2020. wow
yeah with their early early stages right
which is why you said when you said the
Fab the size of the Fab required to make
another Fab is like uh
very large right now oh yeah but
computers were very large
um 80 years ago
and they got pretty tiny and they're
they're people are starting to want to
wear them on their face
in order to escape reality that's the
thing in order to be live inside the
computer there put a screen right here I
don't have to see the rest of you